[Music]  listen carefully  mortal kombat has begun  mortal kombat in theaters and on hbo max  the exact same day rated r  [Music]  listen carefully watch  learn mortal kombat has begun  there's a war coming  we need to fight before it's too late  [Music]  get over here  mortal kombat in theaters and on hbo max  the exact same day radar  it's all real that dragon marking  it's an invitation means you've been  chosen  for what mortal kombat  we don't have much time  well if they want to fight let's give  them money  mortal kombat who's first  theaters and i'm hbo max the exact same  day radar  throughout history different cultures  reference a great tournament  mortal kombat  my name's jax sonia luke kung last  cool i am  [Music]  a dragon marking it's an invitation  means you've been chosen for what mortal  kombat  [Music]  we don't have much time  [Music]  well if they want to fight let's give  them one  mortal combat who's first  in theaters and on hbo max april 16  rated r  you